the most important feature of any system
is its reliability
this is the driving principle behind
site reliability engineering as invented
and practiced at google
this is because you can easily lose the
trust and respect of your users
if your service becomes too unreliable
or simply perceived as being too
unreliable
those countless hours you've spent
designing and building the most amazing
user experiences
are all for nothing if your users can't
access them
but it's not enough to just declare that
your services must be more reliable
reliability must be a shared goal for
many different parts of your
organization
today i'm going to start showing you how
you can consistently define reliability
targets for your services
using slos welcome to engineering for
reliability with google cloud
the first thing we need to define is
what we mean when we say service
for our purposes we'll mostly refer to
one of these three
the first kind of service may be an
application with a user interface
that's accessed by actual humans to
perform various tasks
we refer to those humans as users and we
very much care about keeping them happy
so that they continue to use our service
we'll measure their happiness in terms
of things like
availability and performance
the second kind of service may be an api
accessed by other systems or services to
send or retrieve information
we may refer to the systems that use our
service as consumers
their happiness is also important since
this interaction may involve
exchanging data that will ultimately be
consumed by human users
availability and performance will again
be our key measures of reliability
the final kind of service may be a data
processing pipeline
here we'll care about things like the
throughput of the system its ability to
process data correctly
and the time that it takes data elements
to traverse the entire pipeline
as measures of reliability these three
types of services can end up having
pretty complex architectures and
infrastructures
but they all share the same key feature
reliability
if that's true then we should treat
reliability like other features of our
service
we'll need to plan and design for it
architect for it and measure it
but how do we measure the reliability of
our service
one way to measure reliability would be
to use uptime
or the percentage of time when our
service is up however
up is hard to define and measure and for
complex distributed systems with many
failure modes
this is not very useful instead we can
use an event or interaction based model
we can count the number of times our
users attempt to interact with our
service
over a given time window and divide the
number of successful attempts by that
total
to get a percentage but how do we define
what counts as an interaction
and what makes for a good or successful
interaction
that's going to depend on the kind of
service we're running and managing
for example a website or mobile app can
use http requests separated by status
code as an interaction
the thing we'll actually be counting and
measuring is called the service level
indicator or
sli next we need a definition for
good or successful that will depend on
what our users expect from our service
in this example we're defining success
for the profile page
as receiving an http 200 response code
now that we've defined what success
looks like we need to define what we'll
include in a total or valid set of
requests
for example we may want to exclude 400s
from our account
because those are likely caused by
misconfigured clients and we don't want
our reliability measure to be penalized
as a result
and now our availability slide
definition is complete
here are other potential sli types you
can consider using for your service
the sli menu helps you choose an sli for
your service
based on who your users are what they
expect from your service and how they
use it
okay we know what we're going to use to
measure the reliability of our service
next we're going to set a reliability
target for our service
the target we said is called the slo or
service level
objective it's a combination of our sli
a threshold
and a window of time over which it's
evaluated the key thing we're after
is a target or threshold above which
users are happy
and below which they're not it might be
tempting to set our target at 100
percent
but that would be impossible to meet and
result in not being able to make any
changes to our service in production
we have a simple rule of thumb for where
slo targets should be
a typical user of your service should be
just about happy with the service
when it operates at those targets if the
service was any less reliable
you'd no longer be meeting their
expectations and they would start to
become
unhappy we call this the happiness test
when we talk about the happiness test we
say
barely met because there are downsides
to exceeding your reliability target too
once your users are happy with the
reliability of your service additional
reliability has little value
maybe your users will be happier if
you've built new features or made other
service improvements for the resources
you're dedicating to
far exceeding your reliability targets
we've defined reliability as a key
feature of our service
and agreed to use slis to measure
reliability and slos to set reliability
targets
but how can we actually do those things
let's have a look at how to use
slo monitoring in cloud operations to do
just that
start from the project dashboard in the
cloud console go to the monitoring menu
and select services
this will bring you to the list of
services in your workspace as you can
see in this example there's a long list
of services
services may be created automatically
from app engine services
gke entities the istio service mesh or
antho services
you can also define your own custom
services let's start by figuring out
which of our services are having issues
right now
to do that sort the list by the slos
with firing alert column
you can see that the default service
here is at the top let's have a closer
look at it
we've defined three slos for this
service there's a calendar month
response latency slo which is currently
healthy with plenty of air budgets still
remaining
there's a rolling window availability
slo which is also healthy
finally we have a calendar week latency
slo there's plenty of our budget left
but is currently showing as unhealthy
let's begin to see what's going on
first we can see how our sli is behaving
against our target
in this example we're seeing regular
periods where we're having trouble
meeting that target
the air budget tab shows us our higher
budget burn over the selected interval
this rapid rise is a great example of
why using calendar-based
rather than rolling slos carries risk we
recover
all of our error budget at once when the
calendar period rolls over
rather than by actually increasing
reliability
to further investigate our service we'll
give you a variety of performance and
health metrics
that are automatically gathered for it
because this service was defined based
on the gke namespace
we have access to container pond and
node metrics for that namespace
as an example we can switch to the
container restarts in uptime view
to see how stable our service is we can
see that a number of our containers
restarted right around the same time
further down we can see logs being
emitted by our service and the
kubernetes entity details below that
this is how slo monitoring cloud
operations brings together
all the information you need to measure
the reliability of your services using
slos
and the diagnostic and troubleshooting
information that you might need to
identify
triage and mitigate issues
thanks for joining me today in this
first episode we covered some common
types of services
the importance of treating their
reliability as a key feature
and how to use an interaction-based
model to measure reliability
next we learned about using service
level objectives to set reliability
targets
finally we looked at how to use slo
monitoring in the cloud operations suite
to measure the reliability of your
services using slos
thanks so much for watching don't forget
to like and subscribe to never miss out
on more
engineering for reliability with google
cloud see you soon